it's great to have back on the program
today coleman hughes who's a writer
opinion columnist and host of the
podcast conversations with coleman uh
coleman it's great to have you on again
it's great to be on again so okay let
let's talk about something that's very
much in the news right now a couple
weeks ago cnn reporter jim acosta
just kind of showed up and approached
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene on the street and and kind of
imposed a series of questions to her
about her supposedly not remembering
things she said in the aftermath of the
january 6th
riots or in the immediate
period before it we now are in the midst
of people
mostly pro-choice protesters showing up
at the houses of a few supreme court
justices and protesting at their homes
you also told me about a situation where
right-wing activist candace owens showed
up with a camera crew at the home of a
black lives matter uh
person i kind of want to talk through
your thoughts on these techniques and i
have a few thoughts on them although i i
don't have a sort of completely defined
opinion on them i guess first are these
things the three instances i just
mentioned
are they different or are they the same
in your mind and how would you approach
thinking about them
yeah that's it's interesting too i
haven't formulated my opinion on this
either
um
so i guess there's one distinction to
make is approaching someone on the
street as opposed to knocking on their
door
i'm not sure either is really worse than
the other
although you know one
in a sense knocking on my door is
more of an uh not quite an invasion of
my privacy but a a
sort of questioning of
coming closer to to my private space
knocking on my front door and asking for
some of my attention i can simply say no
there's nothing illegal about it it's an
annoyance
and it's it's unplanned
and there's something
somewhat invasive about it
but i can't say that there's actually
anything truly unethical about it that
would be my first pass at an opinion
it's the kind of thing that maybe i will
think less of the journalist who opts
for this as a plan a
um but
on the other hand maybe they've reached
out to this person 10 times and the
person just won't engage with any media
despite being a public figure so as a
last resort
they're
sort of trying to catch them off guard
that last thing is interesting to me
because my instinct has generally been
okay this is not an approach i use we
make all sorts of interview requests and
sometimes they're ignored or sometimes
they're turned down and i sort of see
that as final like the person has turned
down their opportunity to talk to me
right but then at the same time
sometimes with public servants or with
people in positions that you're
appointed for life
you get the feeling as just a citizen
that they are in a sense beyond an
accountability that it feels like maybe
there should be so for example marjorie
taylor green
um
salary paid by the taxpayer you know
we'll talk more about that because that
could apply to postal workers too or you
know somebody at the dmv i don't know so
we'll talk about whether that's relevant
and
one of 435 legislators someone who has
an impact on policy and law etc and who
can just say i'm not going to answer
questions about what some believe was
her dishonesty at this hearing that took
place in georgia and so is it wrong as a
last resort for jim acosta to show up
there the supreme court justice
appointed for life
um essentially i mean short of some kind
of gross demonstrable
misdeed you you there's no recourse for
saying we're going to remove a supreme
court justice yes they can be impeached
but it doesn't happen
so then you show up at the house i i
don't know that i'm like 98 of the way
to this is not okay
and then the how do you have
accountability is where i i kind of end
up thinking twice
right so you and i are in the same
position as people that interview a lot
of people
uh public figures i don't know how many
politicians necessarily but
we're in a position where we want to
talk to a lot of people that say no to
us and our audiences want us to talk to
a lot of people that say no to us true
and i completely agree with you never in
a million years would i show up at
someone's house so for instance
i i wrote an open letter to ibram x
kendi the author to have a conversation
with me and i in fact you know raised a
gofundme
uh i raised uh you know like 20 over 20
thousand dollars for a
a charity
to connect the event to that cause and
he still didn't want to do it
and it's of a piece with his not wanting
to talk to any of his critics which i
think is a bad thing but never in a
million years would i show up at this
man's house or try to cost him on the
street
and i think it's because
well it's it's i guess it's no more
complicated than the golden rule like if
someone wanted to talk to me and i
didn't want to talk to them and they
showed up at my apartment
uh i would view that as um
almost hostile right it's like
as
you can say that it's just the desire to
talk but it's the desire to talk
where they control the pace of
everything they knew they were they're
prepared i might be in my pajamas for
for all you know
um
and
it's it's also
close enough to a situation where there
is a mob outside my house
where it's it's uh
it's it's going to be very difficult for
me to be in a kind of relaxed state to
engage with you
on equal footing
it's a little bit like shooting downhill
it's like you have the high ground
in
in a battle situation
and i don't want to be really in that
position with someone i'm talking to so
there is something really strange and
almost hostile about it
yeah i would say not even almost i mean
i don't know i was at a restaurant a
couple months ago and i told the story
and someone
was kind of i could tell that they
recognized me and then as i was leaving
they approached me and pretty loudly
they said you jew imperialist bastard
which didn't even accurately reflect my
views on the nuances of the
israeli-palestinian conflict as you can
imagine but nuances of imperialism yeah
uh that that was not um
that was not going to no matter what
that's not going to be a real
conversation and i think maybe part of
what you're getting at is if this is the
catalyst to start the conversation even
if it's only supposed to be a
conversation how good of one is it
really going to be
yeah yeah definitely which is i think
why
i wouldn't do it and probably why you
wouldn't do it but people that are more
into sensationalist sensationalist
journalism and
people for whom just getting the 60
second clip of whatever happens
is
their bread and butter
um
now what about the people who just show
up
they're not journalists the ones showing
up at like you know kavanaugh's house or
whichever justice they're showing up at
they're saying well the supreme court
where all these people are here for life
have made a decision assuming we've been
told the truth of the decision that's
for coming they're making a decision i
don't like there's really no recourse
with these folks and you could say well
you've got to make sure at the state
level then that abortion stays legal
because there won't be a federal rate
and it's it starts to become a well
maybe it is okay to show up at their
house although i would never do that
they would argue
what else can we really do
yeah so
in one sense
the
that's actually a feature not a bug of
american democracy is that the supreme
court
is supposed to be
insulated from that kind of intense
public pressure yes
you know they are one of the
institutions that separate america from
a direct democracy
by design
they're not supposed to be
100 responsive to public outrage or
public reaction they're supposed to be
somewhat insulated from that
so from that point of view
if you think um that feature of american
democracy is good then you probably
shouldn't show up outside of supreme
court justice's house
uh and you know yeah there are
i mean the point of democracy i think is
that we have these
i i really view democracy not as a
system that produces the best policies
all the time i think that's actually too
generous i think what it does better
than other systems of government
is channel the inevitable outrage of
different factions
into a non-violent
process which is if you can vote
it
releases a lot of the steam and anger
that
humans will always build up about
intense issues
and it's like it's like a release valve
on that steam where you can
go to the ballot box instead of the
battlefield and it's essentially a civil
war prevention mechanism in my view
and so when i see things inching closer
to
uh violence and
which is not to say that people
who who show up outside these folks
houses are violent but we know how these
things can sort of spill over sometimes
um i do think it's it's worth
encouraging people to
you know reminding them that we do live
in a democracy you do have
um
you know electoral means of influencing
the laws in your state
and that's probably the wiser way to go
this sort of connects also to the issue
of i mean the the sort of prototypical
situation is a speaker goes to a college
campus
and they were invited often it's by a
conservative group on campus which often
is the minority on campus i will readily
admit at least on some campuses it's the
minority and then there are
protesters against the speaker and
sometimes they're outside the building
but sometimes they're inside and will
rise up as the speech is about to start
and to me that's not really about free
speech per se in the sense of
nobody has a right to speak at a college
so not being invited is not a violation
of anything but at the same time
if you're invited it seems to me
that it's reasonable to expect that you
can at least get your thoughts out and
then during question and answer or
whatever but then the counter always is
when i kind of go this direction coleman
people saying it's not if you just stick
to the norms you'll never really get
anything done by definition activism
that has an impact
may be
inclusive of speech that isn't
comfortable or isn't being done exactly
when it's allowed and it gets to the
idea of the free speech zone that was
generated during george w bush's
presidency where yes you're allowed to
protest but in this box a hundred feet
from the venue for example how do you
think that ties in in terms of the
speech of the speaker
versus the speech of those who say i
don't like this speaker
yeah so the first thing i would say is i
think there's a big difference between
protesting
inside the event which drowns out the
speech okay and protesting outside at
columbia i witnessed lots of protests
like robust protests outside and those
are totally totally valid
and they get the point across they
definitely get the point across that a
lot of people object to the speaker
um
but i say you don't have the right to
just
interrupt any event that you want
because you hate the person and drown it
out
uh so but to your second point this idea
that you know you have to play dirty to
get things done right
and the other side is there's bigotry
and there's
evil and there's all this stuff so if we
play by the rules if we you know we're
just gonna get whatever
i don't i really disagree with that i
mean if you look at
for one thing the most successful
protest movement i would argue in the
history of the country which was the
civil rights movement
um
they they
they took it very seriously to play by
certain norms
because they understood that it was
actually strategically important to do
so so for example
during the march on washington which was
uh organized by bayern rustin and um the
famous 63 march on washington where
martin luther king gave the i have a
dream speech
buyer rustin at the end of that day he
went to a philip randolph
and uh
like embraced him and congratulated him
on the fact that there was not a single
crime
at the whole event with thousands and
thousands of people you understand
what a difficult thing it is to manage
that like blm had so many
protests
and i went to many in new york where at
the beginning
a local blm leader would say
this is a peaceful protest right they
would emphasize that with a bullhorn and
still
there would always be five or ten people
that ended up doing something crazy and
and starting
right so it's incredibly difficult to
actually police the boundaries
within a protest and make sure no one
crosses those boundaries so that you
come across principled and persuasive to
people that don't already agree with you
i think many protesters they
underestimate the backlash phenomenon
which is when you go too far when you
demonstrate that you're willing to like
say you know like hit charles murray and
allison stenger when that happened at
oberlin right to initiate violence you
lose a lot of of good faith among
persuadable people
that see you as as
violent and dangerous revolutionaries
that should be in charge of nothing
right and and even if a lot of people
will only silently form that opinion i
think a lot of modern protest movements
fail to recognize that wisdom which
civil rights leaders really understood
deeply i guess that i
i'm generally sensitive to that
perspective
the the counter that i have is that
there are
a non-insignificant there is a
non-insignificant contingent which will
frame any protest as violent anyway now
that doesn't justify any violence i'm
still against any violence and
criminality but also even if you say
okay well
we're not going to do any physical
violence but we will for example
shut down a road to make our presence
more known because if we just stay on
the sidewalk we're really not even going
to have the impact that we think we need
i think the concern is that there are
actors who will say whatever is being
done other than basically being
invisible is wrong and is a form of
violence regardless and then the
question becomes how do you deal with
the bad faith criticisms that will come
either way
yeah i mean to me i think there is
you know if if i were
in charge of a protest movement sure
i think that this strategic wise route
is to
demonstrate moral seriousness
that is um
you know every every protest movement
that has really
looked back on as something that made
major gains for society whether it be
gandhi in india
or the civil rights movement
or the marriage equality movement
it
key to their success was that they
demonstrated that they were
morally serious people that wanted to
improve and not simply
tear down
and the way to do that even if you're
even if you're disobeying the law in the
context of civil disobedience it's like
rosa parks disobeyed the law martin
luther king disobeyed the law they got
arrested dozens and dozens of times they
were in that sense they were not
um
i mean they they were not just
acquiescing to anything right they were
willing to disobey laws all the time but
precisely because they were doing that
they took very seriously the aim to
demonstrate that they were morally
serious people they were not disobeying
the law just to disobey the law they
were disobeying it because
they thought it needed to be changed and
they were right and it's um
again there are so many failed protest
movements protest movements that
that uh get very little accomplished i
think
it would be very unwise to not observe
the differences between the ones that
work and the ones that don't and that's
one of the big ones are there specific
so part of the examples you gave
as positively
include a sort of assessment by you
partially with the benefit of hindsight
now as to kind of the intentions and i'm
wondering in terms of tactics i mean
think sometimes in environmental
protests there's the
chaining oneself to x and sometimes it's
a tree or sometimes it's the fence at a
nuclear power plant or whatever the case
may be does the tactic itself tell you
much about
the the moral concern
yeah i think the tactic tells you a lot
about the moral concern so for instance
if the tactic this may be too obvious to
say but if the tactic is violent
it automatically
delegitimates the moral concern in most
people's eyes okay it's like if you're
even you know i guess this is a
unless
right so if you're just a terrorist
if you're an environmental terrorist and
you shoot somebody no one is going very
few people are going to be persuaded
right certainly congress is not going to
be persuaded
by that kind of a protest if your tactic
is non-violent
if you spell out exactly
what your principles are and why you're
violating some law
then
that demonstrates a kind of moral
seriousness and that's an actual appeal
to the public
right and and um moreover
to be willing to
suffer on on behalf of your principles
like to to
martin luther king was so committed to
non-violence
in a way that requires such extreme
restraint
right to literally be beaten and saying
that's the ultimate demonstration of
moral seriousness like i'm so serious
about this moral principle and getting
it in the right means that i'm willing
to subject myself to this
that was extremely persuasive to people
absolutely fascinating topic we've been
speaking with coleman hughes you can
check out coleman's podcast
conversations with coleman on which i am
a forthcoming guest uh coleman always
great chatting with you i appreciate
your time anytime david